louder with crowder studios is protected
exclusively by walter
and hopper
i'm telling you at some point something
has to be done
going up against youtube directly as a
suicide mission yeah yeah
youtube i don't care the demonetizations
the restrictions the hard strikes
it's got to stop and if we don't do
something soon there won't be a mug club
left to save
i'm just glad to be here hey kid
what do you plan to do about the 310
tumblers jack
all right
i leave the 310 tumblers to me but right
now
we've got to take care of youtube
right into this world
all alone god takes your soul
live
till you die
foreign
that was me uh pointing actually to
bring in uh our third chair right away
matt matt
matt eisemann on the instagram and you
know why i was actually at a doctor's
office
cover of what is it rheumatoid arthritis
today
i'm like the kim kardashian of the
arthritis world three-time cover man i
will let you know
yeah and the lady said oh is that matt
eisenman oh i just
love him he's the [ __ ] so i'm huge
amongst camps
american ninja warrior america george
junior american injury junior is coming
out october 13th on universal kids
kids age 9 to 14 will be taken on the
course that sounds like childhood
quarterback yes you are in fact your
dad's black right i am yeah
yeah what's up dog yeah let's stop that
okay
i have a question yeah is this my first
time actually being in the third chair
do we get to drink the wine of the day
or do we just talk about it
what is this that's you don't like wine
even actually when we did the big smu
show and he came out and he poured it in
the glass he
leaned in and whispered said you better
not drink that this is welches
you're getting an invoice on the show
today sargon of akkad yeah
then we have glenn beck on the show whoa
and of course we're going to be talking
about kavanaugh everything that you
need to know about kavanaugh there's a
the timeline has been going back and
forth i feel like a lot of people have
been
lost they're getting lost in the shuffle
so we're going to try and clarify that
for you first though the question of the
day the left you know they say right now
to believe
all women because of it's basically a
blatant virtue signaled and
being sent out to mothers and daughters
but what about the message it sends to
fathers and sons
when the left declares them guilty until
proven innocent genuinely i i wonder
what ramifications do you see there
comment below
and why is no one talking about that i
think it's again uh
i think i think it's a great statement
to say believe all women
it's just making that leap to then
convict all men yeah it's that idea of
we certainly want these accusers to feel
heard but then it's this due process
idea of
again okay we will hear you we will
believe that this is a credible thing
but it needs to be investigated before
we draw any conclusions
before we end a career wait do you hear
that that's the sound of your tonight
show
appearance being cancelled oh yeah
i don't know what happened here i just
uh voiced the opinion about my friends
down syndrome i mean mcdonald when norm
mcdonald has become controversial
after saying specifically my show will
not be topical
yeah he sits gets get it there's no way
around it because it's 2018
but first leading the news before we get
to kavanaugh uh batman is going to be
showing off his bat tally whacker
in the new comic book wow it comes from
tmz the uncensored version of the member
only
shows up in print editions of dc's new
quote adult black label series
uh this has been all over trending that
should come as no surprise given who's
been
announced to portray batman i should say
the dark
that makes sense is that carlos danger
that's the worst but best free name ever
i actually i couldn't believe like
because i saw the image of batman's
member which first of all he he's
circumcised you don't have to click the
picture
we can read the story without it you
have to approve that no i i have to
admit that you're 18. here's one of the
things that bothers me is when people
don't actually do the research
on these things and start talking about
them i wanted to see batman's member
okay and see what was going on first of
all he's clipped
so uh okay you know this bruce wayne
could be a jewish family they know
they're wealthy
yeah but but i just thought i i thought
what is this idea of taking
these characters who are so distinctly a
part of childhood and
and trying to make this adult black
label series like well so funny we're
going to make this so dark that we're
going to put a penis in it
and we're going to give him an origin
story where his name was bruce neverwizz
also in the news by the way an arizona
man
faked down syndrome just to hire
caregivers
abc news the first victim reported that
she assisted him with diaper changes
oh my gosh baths on 30 occasions the
second and third victim took over all
said that he would become sexually
aroused as he was being
paid suspicions arose by the way when
police arrived at the scene
and noticed the suspect was not [ __ ]
you just lost your tonight show
appearance norman mcdonald said that
it was just rape it was just regular
non-retarded rape someone says he didn't
just say he was trying to claim down
syndrome
yeah i've worked with i work with
special needs people you can see that
yeah that's kind of an eyeball thing
usually by the way they're jacked
yeah down to the guys you're like oh my
god you do what kind of shrugs are you
doing and it's like i don't know and
they're really happy
well look i look i i don't approve of
this but if you're gonna go this far to
get bathed
okay i can see something at the end of
the rainbow there for you but being
somebody who sits around in a diaper
that's dirty all day
well that's it
that's that's the most disturbing part
of this entire thing for me you wanted
to sit around in your own crap until
somebody changed you
this was also a movie with johnny
knoxville remember that where he was the
ringer yeah
and ended up falling in love that's this
is that was also not a good film this is
not a good story so let's move on to the
international front
uh it doesn't get any better chinese
kindergarten welcomed kids back to
school
with a pole dancer that is the way to go
back
this is this is actually here's a video
this is how they greeted the students
coming back to the school
yeah this this is the assembly
look at the confusion on those kids
you're gonna be a dancer
you need is the pole for fire drill
i don't know what they're expecting when
they're getting their kids to love you
long time elementary it seems
okay i'll tell you what that day i
couldn't wait to get to finger painting
if you don't know what i'm saying you
are among the dads upset
and it's recording is he the
kindergarten teacher i don't know
that was incredible please get in
trouble i'm gonna
i'm going back to kindergarten because
there was training there
either they hired a professional that's
not someone who just got up on the pole
yeah let me just oh look
little kids i dance on paul no this is
of someone who's like super flexible
clearly they've been doing the part they
had the outfit yeah they had the out and
they were ready to go look
they stored it in the teachers lounge uh
i don't know about that look
any time we make fun of your culture
this is why okay this is just one more
reason why shut up all cultures are
equal which
uh well i was gonna say what made it
creepier that poll was actually batman's
member
that was so that's why that was for
kindergarten that was really
much easier without having his head
thank you neva wits all right speaking
of cultures we have to turn our eye now
to ion india
all cultures are equal shut up let's
every everybody let's just agree on this
and uh smuggler arrested at delhi
airport for hiding gold in his posterior
from hindustan times which almost sounds
like a fake newspaper but it's real
on detailed baggage examination and
personal search it was discovered that
the accused had hidden
nine gold bars i don't remember hiding
nine goals
bars nine bars inside
his rectum uh in his defense he claimed
he had down syndrome so again at this
point that's where we're
yeah they're not they're not thrilled i
got do you know how much a gold bar
weighs
do you know what kind of rectal strength
this guy would have to have
and size and capacity yeah i'm trying to
say gold
the other thing is i also just realized
this is the origin story
for goldfinger that was his proctologist
that's how he got the nickname
he's like wow by the way he's he's he's
an actual he's
he's a board-certified md who i am
really so that's why i never found
nine gold bars in a patient well it
would have been what did you find in
there
uh nothing uh nothing at all i'm not
super surprised with my fiance and some
of the stories she's told us about what
she's
heard yeah she should lead people's lead
with the nurse
and there's a man who literally comes in
every single year on his birthday with a
new item
i think the last one was a water hose
i'm not sure yeah it was a garden
like this is his events that's records
yeah he just he's like blow out the
candles and happy anniversary all right
we're going to see this story and out
doing with 10 gold bars finally
statistics actually show that british
police arrest
nine people not we have a female i
remember the russian
i don't remember nine people a day nine
people a day
for posting offensive messages comes
from reason in 2016
3 300 people were detained and
questioned for things they said online
in some parts of britain the arrest rate
for offensive speech
has risen by nearly 900 percent in
recent years so it started off just as
arrests for alleged
islamophobia misgendering [ __ ] uh
but then with soccer um
the police got out of hand where it
seems to be another piss-poor
performance for your
men sister we call you queer chester
but i'm sure you only knew that after
all was
a recent scope
250 plus years ago we gave england the
middle finger
yeah this is exactly freedom of speech
but no you you're honest to good
what amazes me though is you're looking
at these platforms like twitter
and how they talk about the censorship
that goes on in china
and yet clearly while it's not being
censored people are being prosecuted for
it and you would think
that these platforms ostensibly these
last bastions of
speech would be would be against this
would be opposed to this idea that
that people posting simple ideas that
that
would be demonstrably acceptable most
anywhere
it is it is remarkable and and what's
crazy to me too is we protect speech
that's liable
we protect speeches exactly now from the
left as long as it's
a target that they don't like but then
actual speech actual expression whether
it's comedy
to the written word to even honestly
your own in the case of kavanaugh she's
a good example move on to that here
the defamation is what they protect they
look well people are free she doesn't
need to protect her innocence which that
actually brings us to uh you know what
the meat segment for today
for those who haven't kept it straight
let's go on to this everything you
needed to know about kavanaugh but we're
afraid to ask
lion [ __ ] edition allegedly
allegedly i think she said i see i see
matt going like oh no
oh boy okay so let me give you some some
some macro context here for people who
don't really remember the story yeah
remember the story it's still ongoing
but by the time we hit friday by the
time we hit thursday it's hard to
remember what happened on monday yeah
that's where we are so still in news
everyone's talking about the
alleged attempted rape accusation from
dr christine ford by the way no longer
going to be calling your doctor
yeah christine for christine it's just
like
christy christie for your dr christie
all right listen by the way hit the
notification bell
join michael if you haven't already you
get the show every single day 99 dollars
annually 69 for students veterans active
military or there will be no more
crowded confronts or change my mind the
choice is yours let me just say this
of course it's possible that the
accusations here
uh could be accurate right and we're not
saying that all accusations of attempted
rape are false
okay does everyone can everyone we're on
the same page
right do we all agree rape is bad bad
bad rape bad hold on
make sure they say bad a little bit they
can't take it out yeah
but if you look at the way the story
pans out i hope we preface it now um
if you look at the timeline you have to
balance the scales of justice between
there an attempted rape some 30 odd
something years ago that someone doesn't
know when it happened or where it
happened and why he possibly stopped
mid-ray possibly drunk and passed out
or is she a lying [ __ ] we're going to
present the evidence to you
and you decide yes by the way i know
you're saying just me no one else in
this room i labeled her a lying [ __ ]
without proof granted she did the same
but with
attempted rape that's the purpose here
rapist [ __ ] let's see what happens
exactly um
it should be a fair fight we'll see
listen i i hope i hope people are
understanding
the point what's so funny is if you
listen to her attorney did you guys
follow this
ford's lawyer she said well my client
doesn't need to she doesn't need to
prove
the innocence of her case here's what's
been interesting to me with this
is look the statute of limitations
clearly has passed yes
there's not going to be a crime so
obviously this is just to judge is this
guy
does he deserve to have a position on
the supreme court or not and what i
thought was really fascinating was
a group of women who knew him at the
school wrote a letter
attesting to his character like 60. and
then and then and then a contrarian
group
wrote a letter saying we experienced
things that make us feel this is
believable and you realize neither of
those things
have any bearing on this it's just
people saying feelings are things there
are no facts
involved here and there unfortunately no
facts to prove this one way or another i
don't even know if this were if this
were actually in front of a court what
it would look like
okay he didn't hold the door for becky
i don't it's just the lawyer came out
and said oh
my client doesn't need to prove the
innocence of her claim no no you accused
him of rape
do you know anything about the justice
system it's not i accuse you of rape my
claim is true until you prove it false
just
watch and justice for all with al pacino
once
so let's look at this and whether this
could be a a pr
or not here are the fundamental problems
with the allegations against kavanaugh
so let me i have some sources here
because they're important i want to make
sure i get this
right christine ford not doctor i will
not say doctor and i won't say doctor
for you either matt iceman
you watch while people fall in the pools
of four foot deep water
you're not saving humanity anytime soon
sounded like my dad apparently now
they're
nine year olds yeah dunk the nine dunk
the four-year-old in there let's see if
he can swim after
being discombobulated by giant foam pads
the hell is that different it wasn't
entertaining enough
hope you have one hell of a liability
waiver matt um
so if ford has he remotely kept the
details of her own story straight and
the only person who can truly bad for
her
is dianne feinstein now i can't say
everything's truthful i don't know but
i do know that um
you had to contact her lawyers damn it
diane you had one job
just say she's not a lying [ __ ] and you
couldn't do that
so let me recap this for you for accused
kavanagh of attempted rape and a letter
to diane feinstein that feinstein didn't
mention till after the hearings
feinstein said two says she can't vouch
for everything whether it's true or not
four doesn't remember exactly when it
happened or where it happened her story
contradicts the therapist
the attorney story contradicts forwards
an attorney that originally said ford
would testify is now i think saying
that she's not going to testify i was
putting retainer on august at which
point she took a lie detector test for
an accusation she claims she was never
going to make publicly at all should be
noted investigators
are saying that there is still the noted
possibility of ford being
a dirty lying [ __ ] this is the this is
the investigators i mean again again
just if you're gonna say rapist rapist
rapist rapist rapist rapist rapist liar
the [ __ ] is i'll i'll give you it's
just to throw a little spin
it's a curveball yeah exactly there's no
other purpose it's made spirited
so here's what i will i i will add
something here because i want to keep my
job
and i can't tell you how nice
here's what's which what's really hard
and and again i
it feels awful having to issue these
caveats look again
i'm a white man i'm a bigger guy this is
something i probably haven't experienced
so you're a guy what is that bigger guy
in the sense of you and batman
you know again i probably haven't been
put in a situation where you're
pressured
to have like some women
my my point being i i do never want to
diminish this and i think the me too
movement
has brought down a lot of people who
deserve to be brought down sure here's
here's the the the part that that that i
thought it would have been
where i could see this for having some
merit yeah if she brought this story out
and 100 other women came out and said
you know what i had a similar experience
all of a sudden there's credibility
smoke there's fire right but when it's
just been her and we haven't seen this
outpouring of people saying
brett kavanaugh has been this this cad
this
this handsy guy his whole career then i
think it becomes much harder to say
with the absence of any proof how do you
it is not the job of her to provide any
proof
she is innocent proof
what are you talking about i thought
you're supposed to be a doctor look i
think what they've done is they've
hijacked the pound me too movement
okay they really have but feinstein
basically said look how can we delay
this hearing okay here we go we're going
to run on the hashtag me too
right and we're going to we're going to
make an accusation that we don't have to
prove by the way i don't know if anybody
is aware of how our legal system work
you're innocent until proven guilty
here's something else by the way
something that doesn't make sense to me
is the stop mid-rape i've talked about
this yesterday
you either rape or the woman has a gun a
rapist is sick twisted
he he gets off on rape that's why he's
doing it he's a rapist right this we're
supposed to believe he
reaches the big show and just passes out
yeah
every friend jumped on top of him sort
of so i don't know again it'd be like
someone who's in the s
m and he's got the electrodes clamped to
his balls i'm sleeping we're talking
about no no this is the the guy's a
rapist he's what you waited for this is
what he's been waiting for it doesn't
make any sense to me none of it adds up
and here's by the way to go to matt's
point how you differentiate between like
weinstein and cosby
uh from kavanaugh with weinstein and
cause we have verifiable claims proven
in a court of law at least with cosby
even admissions of guilt and i know
confessions can be coerced okay fine but
bear with me here for time places times
witnesses quaaludes
in instances like kavanaugh we have
claims that can't be verified
what's the quality
jello a claim so vague by the way it's
impossible to verify
at all and of course what do we see the
accuser
playing the victim complex this is
what's important when someone comes
forward with an accusation
no proof as a matter of fact something
that could not possibly be proven
and plays a serious victim card that
right away my antenna go up
and you want to believe people but again
we do have to think of the reputations
of people whose lives are absolutely
destroyed
raping somebody terrible crime accusing
somebody of raping somebody
also a horrible crime yes when did it
happen
this is a good question let's just start
with that okay when right who what one
where why
when an original letter four she said
the party happened in the
s somewhere in the 1980s what does that
what does that mean that covers
everything from the empire strikes back
to weekend at bernie's that's a big
that's a very wide spectrum
okay if you were to look at the marquee
at the cinema what and then she said oh
it's 1982.
pick a num it's just it's just it's like
pick a number any number
it's like it's like she's had the shell
cards they just keep moving that shell
game or they're like ah i'm gonna pick
number three rapists
like it's a talking show so in the
original ford letter she says it
happened
in a suburban montgomery home then later
says maybe it was also near a country
club but then she's not sure also she
has no idea how she got home maybe maybe
she was a little drunk convenient
she's the thing we usually find we
usually fact check these claims on the
show
there's no way in this case again
because lying or edition now moving on
if the who what when where why breakdown
is really important we're still missing
the who where
when still so at least two of the other
four people who are supposedly
there at this event deny it happen
here's problem number three
the goal what's the end game here if the
goal is the truth like we were talking
about with michael voris the catholic
church if the goal is to actually fix
the church
if the goal here is the truth having
hearings
aiming for transparency that would be
seeking the truth
that's what ford's lawyers claim is the
goal the truth not politics
i think intention matters i think if we
are trying to really engage in an
inquiry to get it the truth
uh a highly politicized environment such
as the one we're in
is not designed to do that as a matter
of fact they claim that they would do
anything
possible to make sure that the truth
comes to light
would your client be willing to testify
under oath
in front of the full senator skinny ron
perlman my client will do whatever is
necessary
to make sure that the senate judiciary
committee has
the full uh story and the full
uh set of allegations
to allow them to make a fully informed
decision
okay good so that sounds like one of the
republicans the republicans said
okay sure yeah let's have a hearing are
you are you free monday at
monday you don't just close all day
monday
we will clear all of the mon day
does any of that work for you ford's
refusing to attend refusing to prove
any provide any proof of the claims and
again
insisting the fbi should investigate
democrats even think the fbi is like
their oppo research
now i wonder where they could get that
idea like i don't
i i just but the fbi they've already
they've already said no if he was like
no like well we won't we won't do a
hearing until we get the fbi and the fbi
is like that's not
that's not what we're supposed to do do
you know what we do like do you know
like like matt eisenman also isn't like
probably he's probably not your
proctologist i'm mr
incredible i'll go back in time and find
out what happened
well you know with the investigation
which when she says that she wants an
investigation with the fbi one we
already talked about the statute of
limitations too she hasn't brought forth
any proof you've been robbed
okay right tell me how have you been
robbed what was taken from you when all
these
all these things you've gone over too
but was he not a public figure before
this
that could have done irreparable harm
according to them to the public
was he not a judge already before this
and you allowed that to happen you
didn't say
anything and and by the way what is it
that is
makes you wait until the last possible
second i remember it was a story i
remember
i think it was larry craig soliciting
men in public stalls
and his excuse was when i said i take a
wide stance
you were tapped across the urinal yeah
exactly come on but
you remember that was the thing back
yeah and i i can't remember about larry
i think he was a senator if i'm not
mistaken
so this is the guy again who's a very
powerful judge what he has to get to the
supreme court before like i think
do you also i also wonder though where
it sounds like she reached out to
feinstein and maybe
ford thought this this is just something
i'll tell her
and she will use this not knowing all of
a sudden her name's going to be leaked
out there and she's going to get through
no but you know that's going to happen
right and if they were really i mean if
you go to feinstein
it's kind of like um you know what i
want to keep this on the download
that's not red ring ring yes what about
the clinton accusers are they are they
that interested in them or what about
keith no they're all dead keith
ellison's accuser
you know the fbi the fbi is
like no this isn't what this is this
isn't what this is what we do okay
you're saying
there was rape yeah okay let me take
these notes right you're saying
attempted rape
okay so there was no rape right where
you don't know where okay
when you you don't know what any way
so there's still a possibility
potentially that you're lying [ __ ] and
we're the fbi not the fblw i'm not this
is the fbi saying
not me consistently here's the thing if
you look at democrats handling
of this case the left always wants to
operate in the dark quite literally
that's why they turned off the light
during the latest crowded confronts we
walked in and shut off the lights hurry
i was raised in the dark also i'm
sitting on distance
barack obama withholding uh more
information ever
under under the freedom of information
act request for spending 30 spending i
think 36 million dollars
36 million dollars to do so to prosecute
whistleblowers journalists more than any
president before him i think more than
all presidents combined
antifa covering up cameras they want no
accountability liberals screaming about
takedown notices on youtube privacy
complaints even single party consent
states
the accusations of rape right they won't
be there for a hearing because we don't
want to be in the public eye we don't
want to be examined what
generally the good guy is not the one
evading investigation at all costs
generally the good guy wants the truth
to come out with as much transparency as
possible
generally it's the good guy right he
says nothing up my sleeve off with her
right would you like to would you
would you like to pat me down i'm not
looking to do you any harm generally the
guy who has nothing to hide but
not saying you have to submit yourself
to pat downs to every tsa agent that's
not the point
but the point the woman who's like screw
you fuzz
these nail pants not just the new style
that's the person
who is most likely to cause damage the
person allowing you to pat them down the
person saying please
search my house that's not the one who's
in the wrong this is clearly an attempt
to delay the vote
they want zero transparency they want
less info not more this is the mo of the
left
and this is this is why it's so
important i i think this is why this is
happening
don't let me say it let samantha be say
it
is it never the right time to bring up
assault allegations against a rich white
dude
i don't know how about when he didn't do
it yeah possibly
when there's no evidence it's that's
like all the time
for the very small amount of the times
yeah
again and i i look at this and you you
think of the people
you know you saw hardwick or aziz or
some of these guys or you know kavanaugh
if this
ends his bid and you start to say you
know be careful where you see but
but if this becomes the tactic of just
simply an
accusation is enough to end a career
where there's
there's a again and and i i i feel the
need to issue the caveat
of course victims we want them to be
believed no more
rape is
at least unprovable it seems this is
this should sail through
it absolutely with what we know it
should sail i think i think it's
completely
related but unless there's some bomb
that drops but i doubt it i really do
think
this is in my opinion i think it's
completely fabricated and i hope you
understand the point that i'm making if
someone accused someone being a rapist
you know lying [ __ ] is is really that's
just a nickname at that point
i mean come on that was my nickname at
the boy scout summer camp
the point is yeah like you said the left
they want to be able to make the
accusation zero proof
they want to be taken automatically
seriously at their word
given credibility without any
transparency they're not interested in
the truth
at all and here's why they're in a you
know why because they're in a panic yeah
so right now we're what we're two years
in trump's already nominated two supreme
court justices
we've got ruth bader ginsburg and hover
round commercials the grand canyon with
her
fallen and can't get up bracelet and
that's why the left by the way their
netflix documentary i'm like she's a
cool rapping grandma
no no she can't even remember her own
name do your due diligence go look up
the sources we've provided in this
program there's no substance of this
whatsoever that's all you can do is do
your best to research it in this case
there's very little to go on
and that's the idea that's by design
hashtag not all women
are liars but this one right here this
one
just might be so i'm just going to say
liar liar no you know what
if nothing else i can say lying or and
at least i know i'll have a job as a
professor
uh somewhere in texas up next we are
going to have sargon of akkad then glenn
beck yeah
i remember back when mug crow could
upload videos and not be demonetized
but i'll admit
i'm gonna phone this in
when it's time to get away to leave the
hustle and bustle
of everyday life to abandon your worries
the door
there's a place that beckons off golden
coasts of sao paulo
with open arms and snake island
sandy beaches and miles of coastline
with not another human in sight
snake island an actual place averaging
at least
one deadly snake per square meter
crawling
with mother earth's most evil creatures
venomous snakes flying snakes snakes
that hunt in packs
it is literally filled to the brim with
deadly snakes
it's a place that leaves you grateful
for all the modern day basic [ __ ] white
guy problems you have at home
should you ever make it back alive
so pack your depends and book your
travel today
and prepare to ask yourself why the hell
don't we just nuke snake island your
trip begins the gates of hell
that's one of those what are they called
what are those things called uh that you
know the duck that keeps going back to
the water
yeah or the steel balls i have no idea
i've always seen a steel they could be
mercury they could be iron maybe our
next guest knows you can follow him
on the youtube sargon of a cat is a
channel just search sargon of a cat and
he's basically appropriate to that
historical figure
uh sargon how are you sir i'm very well
and
i do i never meant to appropriate it but
i guess it's kind of mine now if you
google my name
if you google his name my picture comes
up
on the official and i'm an ancient
mesopotamian rumor now
i wonder how he feels about it i'm sure
he's not
i'm sure when we get to the afterlife
i'll have a few apologies to
that yes yes because you'll both be in
hell uh let me ask you
what is what is the um what do what are
those do you know the name of what i'm
talking about
those those desk contraptions that they
use they use inertia momentum they're
always
like you know the balls and the duck and
the water what's the term
i don't know they're just office toys
aren't they just yeah exactly no they're
science experiments you should
appreciate this sargon a man of science
sure don't i should i'm not a scientist
and great great ruling
um so okay this is something i wanted to
talk with you about i'm really glad we
were able to get you on the show and i
think we'll have paul joseph watson to
talk about this because
obviously you guys were fingered as it
were uh by rebecca lewis
the data in society reports um the data
and society report this has come out
there's a full report published by this
lady rebecca lewis we're pretty good by
the way with research and in finding
people
this this rebecca lewis just scrubbed
everything
uh often as far as a lot of her previous
content where she is on social media
and it talks basically about alternative
influence
on youtube specifically and we'll bring
this up here the most interesting thing
to me is there's this almost serial
killer
yarn sort of connecting uh
i guess you would call it diagram and
obviously you're featured in it
um and it seems like the goal here is to
get rid of these alternative influencers
have you been following this and how
concerning is it oh yeah yeah it's it's
it's very concerning so
um what i would describe this as is six
degrees of richard spencer
so you can you can plot a course across
this graph and that's the entire point
of this report
right you can plot force from someone
like candace owens
through to dave rubin through to some
black guy through to
andy warski through to jared taylor
through to richard spencer so
effectively candice owens by this report
is running the alternative right
yes so she knew it white supremacists
good job candice i never thought you had
any no
this is exactly what this is about it's
the the point
is the phenomenal influence that the
alternative meter on youtube are having
i mean you know like my channel gets my
channels uh
in total get something like 12 million
views a month yours must get loads
and all the people on here they've all
got very large channels and if you added
all of this up
you're talking probably hundreds of
millions of views a month right and
they've finally realized that
there is actually an alternative and
they call it a legitimate news ecosphere
a fully functional one in fact are the
words that she uses right
and she's just identifying it what i
find interesting is is
she spends just a disproportionate
amount of focus
on much smaller channels i mean i'm glad
don't get me wrong like
they list all of these different
channels like white nationalists and
with with me they're just like stephen
crowder
conservative christian entertainer and
kind of a dick like they don't really
say much
even though we're by far the biggest
channel which to me is interesting
because they're focusing on so many
small channels and drawing 50
connections
usually the smaller channel they're
focusing on would be one that might be
more radical it seems yeah well i mean
the
what what they're focusing on is
connectivity because
they the rebecca lewis she she has
obviously not watched all of these
channels i mean she makes
many factual areas in this report yes
and
that's the main problem with the report
because you know this report is going to
be uncritically used as a reference by
various far left outlets as they're
putting political pressure on youtube
as the wall street journal did with
pewdiepie and as they have done with
various other content creators and over
and over and
it gets it goes you know right to the
top i mean
youtube google they've been called it
for the european parliament they've been
called in front of your senate uh you
know your senate hearings this is this
is
this is big this is not something to
overlook
and this will be used on critically as a
propaganda tool by the left-wing media
to attack and uh not even just
right-wing media i mean there are plenty
of people on here like people like
destiny
people like myself are either left wing
or central that's what i find so funny
is they think that you're more of an
alt-righter than than
myself and neither one of us are
alt-right i'm certainly more
conservative than you i don't know
how they're measuring this they're not
that's the thing
they're measuring it like i said it's
literally just guilt by association it's
it's not about
what the people actually believe it's
about who you can smear
it's about who you can connect to who
for example i debated richard spencer
you know and everyone said oh yeah it's
not my finest hour fine
but there was no doubt that i was
directly opposing richard spencer's view
i mean
that's what a debate is right but when
this was ordered by mother jones
they they the way they reported it is if
me and richard spencer went off armin
armour's buddies after it
and nothing could have been further from
the truth i mean that that debate's got
like half a million views you can go and
watch it
right we're obviously at each other's
throats you know this is like
you're at an old western table playing
cards you were in cahoots and one was
the fall like oh wait he's got an ace up
his sleeve i'm terrible let me leave my
friend carl see
he hates the deal exactly and and i'm
not kidding mother jones literally said
that we both agreed that the white race
was superior and i i'm just like
that was i mean it wasn't even about
racial superiority the debate the debate
was about the politics of
effectively liberalism versus
collectivism right and so the idea that
she
thinks i mean none of this is correct so
i can only assume this is being done
as an ideological propaganda piece well
and we know we know that that's been
going on for a long time
how do you think this is any different
from you know for example using the
southern poverty law center
as one of their fact checkers do you
think this will will lead to any more
severe ramifications again this is a
really really lengthy report
uh people can go check it out at
datasociety.net
i recommend you download the report and
know what they're saying but do you
think that this is something that's
uh more important or or could be more
impactful than some of the crappy
decisions i've already made
yeah and it absolutely could be because
the this this is coming with
what they perceive to be legitimate
academic backing
i mean any anyone who's even glanced at
it will understand that
the the data used is just nonsensical
none of this is actually re it's just
guilt by association so anyone anyone
who
touches this will understand this is not
real but what will happen is it'll just
be
various article after article that just
cite it without referencing it
but this will put collective pressure on
people like susan mcgeeky
to de-platform us and that is exactly
the point what is it
is it what i've been saying it wrong
this whole time who knows yeah
no no i'm saying it wrong and that's
about okay i don't know i assume because
you're the english
you're the english one here that you
would know okay i was giving you the
benefit
i i honestly don't but the milwaukee's
gotten to you sir
you spent one day there and you're
speaking like a hoodlum shame
speaking like a german
the b is fantastic though it is it is so
yeah it's it's going to be used
deliberately to put pressure on youtube
and it's going to be
uncritically examined by the far left
people who will be reading it because
silicon valley where youtube and google
and all the other tech giants are
it's it's incredibly far left it's it's
a it's a it's a monoculture
right and i think i think i think we we
know all of this right we know that it's
a monoculture we know how far left it is
we saw that with james de moray
my concern here is okay is there going
to be some form of escalation because
once you have you know
you have snopes and you have politifact
and you have southern poverty law
center on all of them all of them will
use this
they will use this as if this is all
factually correct right and
the the the main problem i mean
she even addresses this in the report
she says well you know they they
the what i'm going to tell just the
right wing
that she's got here it's not but she she
stretched she states that the right-wing
youtubers are trying to position
themselves as the underdogs as if the
establishment is coming after them as if
they're going to be platformed and yet
they can still upload videos and it's
like well yes there hasn't been mass
censorship yet but it is a creeping
effect
the the slow demonetization the shadow
banning and then i mean have you seen an
alex jones video recently i mean it's
not like i'm a fan of about
that you got tanked in a day well not
only that was like oh they claimed
himself as the underdog
as i write this report with no real
academic substantiation here you go
susan and jack
yeah you're about to say something
quarter black well the thing is that all
of the people that they list in this
article
they always paint with they're the
conspiracy theorists they're the ones
that are making stuff up
you literally have a map of red lines
connecting all of these people together
like
what it's like it looks like the
zodiac's basement like
look stefan molyneux and then carl and
then stephen's here's we don't know what
he does but we don't like them
it's really outlandish and and you'll
notice that the language used in it as
well
is accusatory for things that they
themselves do they'll say
well they're using influencer tactics
they're close with their audiences
they're accountable to their audiences
they you know they they exchange
information in the comments the audience
has a a direct built-in metric system
where they can
show disapproval yeah exactly
imagine being youtube
exactly how awful this is how dare they
upvote and downvote to let us know how
we feel about the content we're giving
them
and the thing is what they what they
understand is that what this does is it
creates loyalty
and and they think that what we're
creating is brand loyalty
as if we're corporations selling a
product when really what we are is just
discussing ideas and talking from
a political politic a particular
political point of view
which is completely normal and it's what
they do all the time
and she says okay go ahead
go she's the objective in the report as
if
you can look at silicon valley and
expect any kind of objectivity
as if you can look at like the far left
publications and they dominate the media
as if there's any kind of objectivity
there and it's
and but the way they write it is as if
they have the monopoly on these things
and we are just a bunch of conspiracy
theorists who have got our
big red line graph on the wall behind
yes exactly
oh this one this wood panel all opens up
and it's just a bunch of red lines
connecting america's crappiest cities
it's got detroit and then milwaukee
somewhere like after stockton
uh but i will say i agree with you
i i i i will say if you say people of a
specific political uh uh
world view or point of view you just
mentioned it's not even that because you
know what your political worldview
matches up very little with mine the
only thing on which we match up really
is that there are people like this
rebecca smith
looking to silence us that's the
commonality you want to find the one
thread connecting the dots that you
could say is legitimate
is people saying ah people like rebecca
lewis and susan wojitsky would however
represent
they want to silence us that's the one
connection
she makes that point she absolutely
observes that she she defines
the fact that our opposition to them
it's not we we are not an ideological
monoculture
i mean i come on here and i disagree
with you in certain points but we can
have a conversation without
screaming names at each other right and
the same i mean i've interviewed a lot
of these all right people and had
debates against them
the the people who subscribe to these
channels are receiving
a greater diversity of viewpoints than
the person and the people who are going
to read this
in silicon valley and various other
places sure we are actually the
the place of intellectual diversity and
they know it yeah and that's
and she actually identifies broadly
speaking and she uses the terms
sjw versus anti-sjw i mean it's actually
like
sunk itself into the lexicon now you
know yeah so that's
that is actually it recognizes this is
just opposition to progressivism well
and that's a problem right it's because
they want to live in the dark just like
when we do the crowd or confronts what
do they do they shut off the lights they
cover up the cameras in this case we're
trying to find rebecca smith to invite
her on the show to discuss this report
they never do this is a program where
you've had naomi wolf
all the way to glenn beck to sargon of
akad to alex jones to ben shapiro take
your pick
we will have anyone on who is willing to
have an actual discussion that is
somewhat
it just doesn't even have to be that
productive at least somewhat productive
they
want to operate in the dark it's the
only place they can live
they're like uh stalactites all right
that is sargon of akkad
at the youtube no no no i thought you
were saying correct
no no no that's absolutely right yeah i
mean the thing is that the whole point
about this is censorship
that's the point she's identifying the
people to censor that's the that's the
fundamental point i thought you were
doing this like correcting me like oh
he's been banned already just during
this interview
uh okay sargon of akkad on youtube thank
you so much for being here sir stay safe
in milwaukee
my pleasure
there it is again so strong
yeah freedom tell them about them
tell them where they can find mug club
matt you're a member oh go to louder
with crowd if you only pay
99 or 69 if you're a student or active
military one other classification
veteran veteran even if they're inactive
69 bucks a year you get cr tv not only
to get louder with crowder
you can get great shows like mark levine
and you can get gavin mcguin
mcgingus as michael mallis likes to call
him all the great shows on cr tv
mug club makes it happen i am actually
very concerned he knew all the price
points and the plugs i
you just said you want to do the library
and he just did it he will be escorted
by armed security very shortly louder
with credit.com
club cheers
i think in this thing i close my eyes
and there you are yeah i don't but
uh either the i think the person's on
hallucinogenics
i think what the i think the song is
supposed to be uh but
i i don't know if they're mushrooms you
and your you and your drug paraphernalia
get out of here this is a family show
really glad to have our next guest on uh
i've performed with him live i've been
on his show multiple times he's actually
been on this show quite a few times
uh you can follow him as long as i still
allow him on the twitter at glenn beck
and his new book
is addicted to outrage mr beck thank you
for being here sir
how you doing stephen i am doing well
now you mentioned ray
i'm a little upset that uh you're doing
this interview wearing pants
i you know you know well here you know
what okay let's
you you and i know how rumors can get
spread mr beck those were ranger panties
also known as softies okay so apparently
just no one else aside from me respects
the men and women of our armed services
because that's what they wear in
well i think that's fine i again that
had nothing to do with my statement i
was disappointed that you're
oh okay you're doing this interview
while wearing pants oh okay so just just
separate statements
separate statements just just i'm not
wearing pants if that helps
let's take the interview this direction
who are you to judge
who are you to judge no one can judge
anything anymore at all
even uh allegations against uh somebody
being a
in a let an alleged rapist 35 years ago
don't know the time and place no proof
and by the way
it's not my job too it's not my job you
know glenn
to uh to prove my innocence in accusing
you of being a rapist
no it is not it is not i mean it used to
be this is old-timey
you know that you're innocent until
proven guilty and you had to prove the
person's guilt
they were you know that that's the way
it worked but i don't like that standard
no no i like i i yeah you know and and
steven i mean let's
let's be honest uh i think you should
fess up to what you did in kindergarten
yeah you know uh revolving pants yeah
well it always goes but i thought you
were gonna say
you know you just say what you did to a
kindergartner cause you could throw that
out right now and i just say hey no i
didn't you'd be like it's not my job to
say that you didn't do something with a
kindergartener you you disgusting
horrible human being and i'm like oh
crap we're playing by those rules now
cuff me boys that was it did you
see the attorneys you wouldn't go to
jail you wouldn't go to jail you would
just have your life destroyed yes
exactly actually you don't go to jail
you don't have trial
you just you just have your life
destroyed okay so this actually comes
back to you know the point with with
your book i don't have it in front of me
i know i'm getting a copy soon and
you'll be back in the studio uh there
you go
addicted to outrage available wherever
books are sold
you've managed to avoid this quite a bit
though on the personal sort of
moral attacks you know that in with the
hashtag metoo movement
you really haven't had anything like
that and that's that's pretty remarkable
considering the span of your career
i mean people hate you some people hate
you don't look at me
nobody's gonna believe any woman no one
would believe anything
they'd be like oh i don't believe it
look
at him listen glenn i'm going to say
this i'm going to give you a compliment
and then immediately uh contradict
myself you know listen in the realm of
like actors
okay listen you're not you know you're
no young alec baldwin in the realm of
conservative hosts
you are as attract you're very
attractive right so
and certainly compared to harvey
weinstein you're doing what you're doing
you're doing well you know you're right
on that thank you that
means the world i'm going to cherish
those words stephen
how do you think you've avoided because
people have gone after you for your
ideas or they've gone after you for your
you know the way you presented your
ideas but you really haven't had the
same kind of
personal attacks on your character as
far as the sexual stuff yeah
the sexual stuff no the sexual stuff no
yeah and i
just you know i mean i i you know my my
my wife would love to because she would
not be the obedient little wife that
said no no my husband
she's like get out of here yeah i'm glad
he's gone
um but i think i think the way you avoid
it is
um one thing that i i do and i've done
since i was
uh at fox is i'm not alone
in a meeting or a room with a woman
or a man really for that matter yeah
really ever
i mean my my office you've seen it it's
the exact opposite of uh
matt lauer right it's completely glass
the walls
but it's exactly the same as anthony
weiner's but for entirely different
reasons
um no but that's a good that's a good
point so you and mike pence we've been
told are secret
you're closeted rapist right now with
mike pence like well you don't trust
yourself alone with a woman
it's like come on take your pick people
no it's
you know what it's not for me it's not
anything other than
i know how this works right you know
when you're under attack for political
purposes and you've had people
investigate you and you know even your
own employer
do like a hatchet job looking going
through your garbage
you know you you you start to take
precautions that anybody can claim
anything and so we just
i've always just taken the precaution of
i'm not going to be alone with anyone
because then it's
my word against their word and then it
comes down to
which one's more popular with the media
and i know it's not me
well well i that's certainly not me
either especially with a new data
analytics report we were just talking
about
uh so but your book addicted to outrage
let me let me get into this
why why write this book what is so
important you think about this book
uh right now and i guess sort of
summarize it for people who aren't
familiar with it
you know i think because stephen you're
a good example of this i
love i love when you go out and say just
change my mind
and you have a rational conversation
with somebody you know how you don't
hate them you're not throwing you know
names back and forth at each other
change my mind i'm willing to have my
mind changed
nobody's nobody's doing that and we're
starting to get so outraged over things
like you know the freaking
muppets yeah they're gay they're felt
puppets man their eyes are glued on
what are you talking about or they like
having glue shoved in their eyes that's
the problem now we don't know what
they're doing
we don't know what that frank oz was
doing get the hot poker
i'm sorry so uh
so they're uh you know so we don't
really actually we're not talking to
each other and it's just hardening our
positions
and we have to and i i think the good
news is
uh that there is probably i think
there's 60 maybe 70
of the the country that doesn't want to
play this game anymore they're tired of
it you know they're tired of the games
and
just you know like you just changed my
mind well i think i think there are a
lot
who who would you say is is most to
blame for the the outrage
addiction here in the country uh we can
obviously go left right we can go
academia entertain
is it media you know there are a lot of
sort of voice divided
um i think it's academia because it
started really in academia
you know it's the i focus in the book on
the post-modernists
uh and you know if you know anything
about the post-modern it's been around
for a while but it really became
weaponized
um in the early 1970s late 1960s in
paris
when they came over and started
introducing it into american academia
i mean they're on the tarmac and they're
talking about you realize we're about to
uh unleash a plague on this society
right
uh and and it's just gotten worse and
worse and worse and people don't
understand post-modernism they don't
understand
uh the rules and it's it's why everybody
gets so wound up
and it's why we're looking at kavanaugh
today and having
something that we always would have said
he said she said i can't make a decision
here there's nothing here
right maybe he did it maybe he didn't
maybe she's lying maybe she's telling
the truth
i don't know yeah we would have moved on
we wouldn't have we would have had the
decency not to even bring this
to the people because it hurt the person
who could have been innocent right
exactly and they're really honestly the
more
more that comes out with this right but
but you know buying some bombshell it
really does seem like as though it's
entirely fabricated that's just my
opinion when you go home
entirely what fabricated it seems
entirely fabricated i think so too yeah
this is just opinion yeah it could be
it could be you know i'd like to hear
some facts
i don't understand a rapist stopping
mid-rape no one can explain that to me
it's like this is what they do they're
filthy
they're filthy horrible people bury them
beneath the train tracks okay make sure
everyone understands
hate rape everybody because they're sick
and twisted right
if they are starting a rape they don't
just stop this is where the adrenaline
dumped
this is the big show i either there's
rape
or you have a gun as a woman but i guess
we we're supposed to believe people got
drunk and passed out
and stopped raping no no but but here's
the here's what
they're claiming and i'm trying to
remember what happened again exactly
today
talking about the fbi the fbi does not
investigate this
this is investigated at the state level
and it's and
what they're claiming now is a
misdemeanor it's
it's one year um of
um uh what do you call it community
service
now limited uh statute of limitations so
it's one year it's been 37 years
this is a misdemeanor meaning he groped
her he
held her down he touched her through her
clothes
and then it was over felony is different
wait a minute we're we're destroying
people's careers over something that no
one has any evidence of
and you can't get the fbi to
to investigate because this isn't the
fbi's job no because they couldn't they
couldn't possibly and of course this
happens day in and day out on
on campuses across the country with
these sort of campus tribunals let me
ask you this because we talk about the
outrage culture right
this is a good example the outrage at
kavanaugh
but what they are doing right here that
is outrageous
so what is obviously a measured response
obviously presenting facts and
information but when you have people who
are willing to slander or commit libel
um what do you do i mean i'm of the
belief that you don't find middle ground
with evil there are people with whom you
can find middle ground but you have to
recognize those who you can't
uh what's your take on so i i i think
you're exactly right
um you know you can't um this book is
not aimed towards washington
it's not aimed to the you know people
who are playing politics and it's not
aimed to those people who are just
die hard never gonna they will oh they
will never say a bad word about the
president be it
uh trump or be it obama doesn't matter
cut from the same cloth they hung the
moon in the stars and i will
never say a bad word my way on the
highway
those people are out but i think there
are a lot of people that don't want to
engage in this
and um by you've read have you read um
uh either the uh coddling of the
american mind or the righteous mind by
uh
jonathan height i've read portions of
the righteous mind not the coddling of
the american mind
all right uh so the the righteous mind
is great and if you see that what is his
point is
sometimes not not with the extremes but
we're saying the same things
we're just approaching it in a different
way right and by
by demonizing each other uh and by
fighting back you're not going to be
able to make an
impact they're not going to come they're
not going to come your way
if you're always screaming at them that
they're stupid yeah well what if you're
not screaming well a good example like
so we do change my mind that's our first
option but just recently we did a
crowder conference is another segment
where this professor at ut arlington
said i threatened to kill his children
posted false memes of me saying you know
gas all the
derogatory terms f for jews which is
actually a these were memes spread about
me turns out by a neo-nazi website who
didn't like me for supporting israel
this professor realized it was fake he
continued with it and said this man
actively has told me he will kill my son
he will kill my family and was teaching
his students
we called the campus dean they did
nothing we called the campus police
no report was filed from him by the way
we called the campus lawyer
nothing so that's where we uh we we
invaded his classroom and uh with a
bristol board of all of the things that
he claimed
because i do think that at a certain
point we're not confronting these people
yeah we're at a certain point you're not
confronting these people
just to fight them or say they're stupid
you're confronting them for everyone
else
watching uh but of course the first
choices change my mind or
or any of these debates yeah there's
there's there's a real difference i mean
you're exactly right on evil you don't
negotiate with evil and you don't you
don't abide with
evil you don't live next next to it and
just look the other way
absolutely right right so there's a
difference between you know some outrage
is warranted uh and some things have to
be stopped
but i'm convinced that uh the left is
going
so far i mean i hear people on the left
all the time will come up to me and say
i have to tell you i am more afraid of
my side than your side we're getting
spooky
there are these democrats democrats
locally your neighbors not talking about
the people in washington or you know
sure going to louis farrakhan
conferences
those people are starting to be
uncomfortable
with the people that their party is
hanging out with
and abiding by yeah those are the people
that we have to talk to
right and if your neighbor's fairy can
you have problems
i'm just mowing the lawn and the jews
cause all wars
okay louis see you tomorrow uh
all right we do have to go i know i'll
have you back in the studio for a longer
segment it is at glenn beck as long as
they allow it show the book one more
time
addicted to outrage let them see it let
them see it it's on amazon right
is there there are still physical book
stores i think
yeah i think they're all i think i
haven't been in one for
i swear to you the barnes and noble near
me became a barnes and noble's
cafe they don't sell books they just
sell coffee
so i i don't know anymore no i didn't
get the audiobook the audiobook's really
really good
that's true and plus you sound like a
narrator had a baby with james spader so
i actually think the audiobook might be
the way that i go oh i'm driving
yeah glenn thank you so much sir i know
you're tired i appreciate you coming and
we'll have you back on soon
thank you we'll be back to wrap this up
greetings america hopper crowder here
telling you that you should follow
uh stephen on instagram at ladder with
crowder
because a lot of pictures of me it's
good vibes all around unlike the comment
section and
the only thing is it doesn't have steven
crowder it's louder with crowder because
that guy's a dick
that one's called the the cindy i knew a
girl named cindy who claimed she
couldn't go under water that pinching
her nose he'd be like just listen just
don't let the note just don't breathe in
shoot
i can't i can't that's my wife she casts
internet every time i don't understand
is this a thing yeah
it's a common thing it's a mental
comment below all the female viewers who
we have and i know
youtube we have a lot more who are mug
club members funny enough but uh yeah i
met a lot of them at uh
i mean a lot of women don't my ears
pinching my nose women don't like going
in the comment section on youtube
we have a lot of female viewers not a
lot of female commenters
uh and i'm pretty sure most of them are
catfish yeah but i don't know what this
is she like she would always think
and you'd panic uh thank you you got
into drowning dance uh matt heisman
oh yeah what's again so obviously matt
eisemann on on twitter
yeah instagram facebook and then uh
american ninja warrior jr on universal
kids
october 13th october 13th they get a day
off from the nike factory thank you for
helping them out
um they got to stand for something they
did stand for something
you know i wanted to bring this out and
there's there's there are a couple of
reasons for this so
this right here because i wanted to give
some credit to someone who don't get to
talk about the show
you know what this is you mean yeah i
think garrett knows i know
garrett knows that prince we're going to
play a little game here and this is
honestly to to just thank the people
here
at the show and specifically one unsung
hero who uh i don't talk about enough
this my i don't know how how do i unload
this uh there
oh it's just a big stack it's just a big
stack this is
for people this is when we talk about
why we've missed shows or something for
a crowd or confronts or changing my mind
like what are you doing listen we're not
at home reading the
member dc comics okay uh
this is one year's worth of loud earth
crowder writing
wow just the last one and it doesn't
have research so all the sources you
just saw
it doesn't include any of that and so no
nothing up by sleeves i'm going to do
here is uh matt i'm just going to run my
finger through and then you just
tell me when to stop okay okay okay okay
okay stop
all right well i'm gonna have to grab
out a few sheets now because
it's kind of heavy yes that's the thing
i think some of them are yeah i've been
doing you can
you skip an arm day there that's skip
all right which one which one this sir
this
this lost a page well what just came out
here all right this is
let me read it exactly seriously that is
toxic it's violent but the good news is
you just need to change you become
more like a woman there's truth i know
tens of millions of boys
do you think he's more likely to become
a compassionate husband a loving father
what is this i'm trying to remember what
this was even from what is that
i've had nightmares where i just get
killed by
oh this was the please think of the
children closing segment oh someone
please think of the children why don't
you think of the children
right you know i believe in our future
yes yes exactly
uh there you go yeah something toned up
all right let's try it one more just so
people don't think we're making this up
let's
let's let's go let's have let's make
this all right keep it going keep going
this is a magic trick doesn't matter
doesn't matter only it's like david
blaine where he actually just stabs
himself
magic tricks you're just a wizard you
just
we just spent time in burton ernie's
dungeons it's up there it's up there i
want something on the top something
recent
okay or it could be from the end i don't
know how you did it i'll grab a couple
pages so i can i need
any context because sometimes i don't
understand what the stuff is all right
we'll just grab this here anywhere here
this
is all right again can i see the writing
on this
this is um
this is uh episode 209 i was born in the
darkness
africa enters space race with ghana's
first satellite we have footage of it
being launched plus that's where we did
a really really crappy ghana satellite
you know a little bit of rain there
and chinese restaurant offering
discounts based on bra size
and that was a honey stuff you brought
we going to dinner
that was one of their best joke uh and
then
also guess who just opened up a
corporate account and i think it was
eric bowling at the chinese restaurant
if i'm not mistaken
or it could have been harvey weinstein
harvey weinstein we'll try that post
anyway
the point is this allegedly apparently
we also know woody allen likes to eat
chinese yes
oh oh i like if i could have a job
i don't know i don't know which i
protect to keep my figure
also i'm a pedophile i just you know was
that woody walking
woody no it was it was just for walking
with wonka woody wonka
i i i molested my my my nine-year-old
asian adoptee therefore i get
nothing um this is korea's
sanctions passed over kim jong-un
promised fold revenge uh but first had
to stop at super cuts
do you remember when we were worried
about korea i know what happened i don't
know they still have dudes this one was
funny by the way because we had a
an image of it we actually have i have
it written right here see it says 1985
lesbian
we went into a 1985 hairdo book and
found the clearly lesbian haircut and it
was the kim jong-un
oh wow so sometimes i read these notes
anyway
hold on
so uh the reason i i bring that up is
not because it's a little bit
yes i wrote that stuff uh i know but i
threw it so you could hear the thought
i was hoping that you would you know
pick it up and be like oh my fingers and
i'm like
arthritis
short lifespan because you're tall uh so
but the thing is
everyone here works hard but there is
one one person in the team with whom
none of this would be possible that's my
wife and i i i haven't really talked
about this
a lot i've talked about how i like my
wife i've talked about how i i really it
does bother when people they only bad
mouth their life i get breaking balls
uh but when it's the only thing you do
hey listen i love my wife
simple and there's a big reason for that
there's a big reason that i've promoted
the institution
and the idea of marriage so when people
often come to this closing segment like
looking for either advice or some kind
of inspiration
hopefully this helps it's not really
sexy and that's why we don't talk about
it a lot
um it's not just because marriage is is
important
foundationally to society but because it
makes your life better how does this
affect you how does this help you
we can take 12-step programs rules to
improve your life we can talk about all
that read all the books all that's valid
by the way all that's good
but all of it all of it pales in
comparison
to finding a good loving wife or husband
to the women who are clearly not in the
comments section
because a man who finds a wife finds
that
which is good and the same for a woman
who finds a husband i've had a tough
year uh health problems growing business
or trying to keep up with making some
hires by the way
we're looking for two more editors and
uh a pa so if you think that's you
uh photoshop experience video and then
pa hyperly organized we need someone who
can
get us coffees um don't email team
crowder because that guy sounded like he
was a dick
stephen when he was a teenager he's
don't email him getting his own spin-off
from dc by the way
you're definitely not going back rabies
jobs
but it's been a tough year you know
health problems growing business we're
trying to keep up with some
some deeply personal uh issues that
we've been dealing with behind the
scenes it kind of kind of honestly just
break your heart
and to get through it uh i'm able to get
up it god knows what hour in the day to
slog through all of this that you see
for you
obviously the fans matter an incredible
deal but i still wouldn't be able to do
it just with you i know you mean a lot
more club members without the support of
my wife
it's it's the one person who i know will
always
be there and when people ask for advice
this is such a huge component to it most
of us really just aren't complete
most of us are not even in the vicinity
of complete
without the right partner sorry so i
realized matt's older and unmarried and
his parents have been on and this is the
worst club oh no i just i love i love uh
when you quote jerry maguire
so does tom cruise because i couldn't
share it with you
you mean you mean travolta stop it
that won't make fine all right hold on
let me get ernest here because i know
you want the inspiration but this is
honestly
this is it really is an amazing thing
and that also means a selection process
is one that deserves respect it doesn't
matter if you like to say movies if you
both like doing old pentax cameras or
whatever the hell else your
hipster christian pastor or friends tell
you should be on the priority list
picking the person you're going to spend
the rest of your life with is not only
pivotal but it also will determine
probably it's probably the big
biggest determining factor biggest
single determining factor in your
personal happiness
uh for husbands what does that mean that
means finding a woman who's yep loving
supportive strong loyal
most of all has already so these are
things that will say gender neutral i
know we'll say loving supportive yeah i
list that first for a woman
not in the same way that i would for men
and i'll explain to you why i am a
complementarianist i do believe in
complementarianism sorry traditional
western christian
you're already here anyway but what's
most important is that you find a woman
who's already lived the values that
you're looking for in a woman and they
may not be the same value that i'm
looking for in a woman
i'm just talking to whoever is out there
and i got a specific email you know who
you are
look for someone who's already living it
before you show up for women
it means finding a husband with a
backbone will provide protect of course
but is also gentle
tender with you willing to listen that's
a big thing i wasn't that
when we first got married i was not a
great listener i was not a great
listener they diagnosed with adhd which
i did not believe in and they had me do
all these eeg tests
and then they did genetic testing and
then they finally had me read a book
called honey are you listening
and i and i didn't read it but what i
did
i swear i moved the bookmark throughout
the book
because i knew my wife was checking up
on me to see if i was reading it oh yeah
and when they brought me to the
therapist i said
were you just moving the bookmark i said
yes yes i did that's what i was doing i
didn't lie about it proactively
and the something else you've both got
to have a servant's heart now listen
don't take it from me go read that book
called the bible it talks about that but
it's also really practical even if you
just believe it in some archetypal sense
so it means that both of you have to
live to serve one another because the
stupid idea that we hear all the time
and i hear this a lot this is what we
see in romantic comics oh he'll love me
just the way i
am bullcrap okay yes he loves you but
you could use improvement work on it
he loves you period you need improvement
period
work on it or the men who [ __ ] she's
you know she's always trying to change
me bro women they're always trying to
change you
you know what maybe you could use some
change be open-minded here mr low-cut
pants and tank top
i'm going to ke i think we're you wanted
to say something a quarter black yard
and then i gotta
no yeah lay in this plane that that
point is very poignant for me uh
recently we were out at owen's show and
we met a couple great
uh mug clubbers from chicago so if you
know you're right there yeah
uh and i'm probably dead now i
completely messed up the interaction
the like small talk and then after we
just kind of talked about it and she
kind of worked me through
like hey this is like things you can do
to improve
yourself and interactions with people
yeah i mean
that's what's so great about being
married you have a really nice wife
yeah i don't listen among the best
quality my wife or her that conversation
is
this it's this it's like george costanza
and i get the message right away and
sometimes when we first got married i
swear i'd be like why are you hitting me
in front of us you're not a good
listener
so this is the thing marriage is not
this is one that's really important
this will improve your life not only
improve society for jordan peterson talk
about this
but individually i can tell you it is
the single greatest improvement the
single
most important decision that i've made
in my life but marriage is not about two
people who are perfect for each other
that's a lie it's the exact opposite
it's the marrying of two very flawed
very sinful
very imperfect people to become one
greater
than the individual you go in knowing
that with eyes wide open
wow that's when things click but rather
than fight the self-improvement the
self-change you got to embrace it let me
tell you what i love most about my wife
she's not as she's not necessarily as
gentle with me and you know what i
wouldn't do well you think i would do
well with the wife who was that
no i need a wife who smacks me around
every now and then you should see
our basement her st things i like about
my wife
uh number one her strength this is the
irony right we talk about
talk about this whether it's my mom
whether it's my wife uh your wife
uh i don't know a single conservative
woman who who's a shrinking violet
a single conservative woman a single
woman who is right leaning who is active
in their points of view who's i've never
met one it's never happened the only
weak women i've ever met the only
perpetual victims i've ever met are left
as feminists
my wife complete opposite her strength
her loyalty
i don't think i've ever seen anyone in
my life uh as loyal and
you know there are a lot of other
reasons but as loyal and trustworthy as
my wife and in this era of the me too
movement and i was thinking about this
the baseless accusations i have
zero concerns none zero but my wife's
intentions
and she can say the same about me i love
that about her and her juicy heart
shaped tiny i had to throw that in there
but it should i know it was stupid man
okay no you know what no
this is the thing if you go in and
you're marrying someone who's already
lived the values that you want to see
and you are you can't be asking it from
somebody but you're doing it as well
that changes everything she puts up with
a lot my wife i know it she knows it
but all this works out you see all of it
none of it happens
none of this happens none of this show
happens none of this works out none of
it comes to fruition without the wives
and the husbands of the people who work
on the show do we have husbands actually
well yeah yeah okay one woman has a
husband and then we have a
few cute maddie who's too young to be
married but she's not too young she's
just she's not married yet
watch she's gonna have so many seniors
now but really the wives and the
husbands who may not be on the payroll
who may not be on the employee list and
we're continually hiring
they really do help make this show
happen and a big part of this knowing no
matter what happens no matter how hard
i fail no matter who tries to sell me
out to the devil himself
and this is what could happen for any of
us with this new movement of baseless
accusations
that i'll come home to a loving wife who
i can trust love and and man we used to
turn priceless so often it's meaningless
but that really is something priceless
it's not just peace of mind
it's a calming of the soul and so i know
these these supposed
in cells out there and the people who
[ __ ] about alimony and
men's rights they're not going to like
to hear this but the truth is if you
were to map out your life right now
you want to talk about self-improvement
we've talked about be the guy who does
something
okay pick a goal any goal start moving
toward it if you were to map out your
life
right now and you were to say okay i
want to chart a course to a lifetime of
happiness
of peace the one decision you could make
is
finding the right wife or husband
and that means a serious pruning process
for you because she may see you as a
project but no self-respecting woman by
the way is going to want to link up with
a guy who doesn't have any of his crap
together
but if you were to make one decision or
a series of decisions that would lead to
a longer happier more peaceful
fulfilling life
this is it one of my favorite films of
all time is actually uh rushmore
uh wes anderson film earlier west
sanderson film and ain't it bill murray
he turns to uh a character max fisher he
says
what's the secret max and max is beaming
from ear to ear with a smile
jason schwartzman's character and he
responds says ah i don't know i guess
it's just finding something you love to
do and doing it for the rest of your
life
if you do it right that's what marriage
is there's someone i love
there's someone who loves me there's
someone who's willing to be there for me
for the rest
of my life that can be you
don't buy the hollywood hype finding a
wife is finding something
that is good and it is finding wait did
i just say that
i do my wife for the rest of my life i'm
trying to think of my verbage let's cut
let's let's cut
we'll see you next week
you